[Music]
when I look up at the stars it's very
hard not to think about big questions
but you know it can turn I think anyone
into a philosopher and you're looking
back in time you're looking at something
that's such an immense distance your
brain can't even compute it
[Music]
I'm livery and my educational background
is in astrophysics and I've been
absolutely fascinated with space ever
since I was a little girl I grew up in
Kent and University I studied physics
with astrophysics using the language of
mathematics to figure out mechanisms and
processes behind the nature of reality
itself but now I'm a poker player
primarily the game of No Limit Hold'em
is a game of incomplete information
there is more unique situations in a
game of No Limit Hold'em than there are
atoms in the universe
it's crazy complicated that's just
numbers on a mind-boggling scale and
that's why I love about the game it's
about being as methodical as you can but
also adding this sort of intuitive Flair
of how to read humans as well poker and
in particular heads-up No Limit Texas
Hold'em poker has become the leading
benchmark in the AI community for
solving imperfect information games
I am dr. Thomas Santo I'm a professor in
the computer science department at
Carnegie Mellon University we developed
the strategy for Lee brothers Lee
brothers is the first opera I run on
bridges which is the newest
supercomputer at the Pittsburgh
supercomputing Center Britta's is the
largest system in the world the
converges high-performance computing
with artificial intelligence and big
data I'm Nick Nystrom I'm interim
director at the Pittsburgh
supercomputing Center pairing Leigh
brothers with the HPE superior bridges
we really made history
I remember hearing about a team of some
of the very best No Limit heads up
players we're going to be playing
against LeBron us and we all watched it
fairly closely to see how a human mind
is matched up against a supercomputer a
key aspect is that there are both
multiple players and missing information
the algorithms automatically created the
poker strategy for the problems defeat
the humans in real time at the game
they're Garcia
down with the groundbreaking moment here
to me it was a demonstration of the
power of the human mind because it takes
a supercomputer to start beating some of
the best minds in poker and now the
question is where do we take it from
there what else do we apply it to like
you can apply science to poker you can
apply science to fixing the world's
problems the algorithms are my brother's
give you a plug do situations where
we're missing information precision
medicine global hunger climate
environmental damage the possibilities
really are eliminated only bare
imagination
what I'm most personally excited about
is the application of supercomputing in
AI to solve some of these really big
questions that we have about the nature
of the universe itself in some ways we
are tiny and insignificant but at the
same time we also have incredible
potential with our minds and the things
that we can do with them
[Music]